combine your passions
if you're starting a business and you're
not sure which one to do you've got a
few ideas that might become
opportunities for you
find a way to combine them into one
business because that's what's going to
help separate you from everybody else so
you're not just a real estate agent
you're not just selling chairs you're
not just whatever it is but you combine
them and that's what helps you stand out
from everybody else so i got a great
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys uh 4c natural hair real
inspiration that's a good name uh wrote
in the same my question is i have so
many different business ventures my
passion and love is for youth but i've
also engaged in a few other business
opportunities is it important to only
focus on one business venture at a time
when you're just getting started so what
i would do
is here combine them so i don't know
what your other ventures are but you
love youth
so if you're doing something around hair
because that's what's in your name
do youth and hair combined so focus on
not just hair because everybody can do
hair there's tons of people who are
doing hair
do hair for youth
make that your niche make that what
you're really excited about and then
people will come to you because you're
known as the person who helps young
people with their hair that's how you
stand out right if you i don't know what
you're doing with hair if you have your
own salon or that's your ambition you
want to cut hair think about how many
people cut hair
think about how many how many stores how
many barbers are there there's tons
here's a way for you to stand out
you focus on youth
and maybe you also focus on inspiration
in here
real inspiration
bring that in there too
so now if i'm setting up this new salon
i'm focusing on youth i'm focusing on
hair and i'm focusing on inspiration so
when i come in i'm gonna see signs
on the wall of inspirational quotes
inspirational sayings helping young
people think about their life so when
they come in to your place now it's not
just getting your hair cut
it's coming out a new person
your life has changed
by coming into your place
and that's how you're going to stand out
and separate yourself from every other
salon that's out there
so whatever your different [ __ ]
ventures are instead of keeping them
separate
bring them together to make one amazing
awesome opportunity and find ways to
integrate all of your passions into your
one business
you'll feel happier you'll feel more
fulfilled you won't feel like things are
missing from your life you'll have a way
bigger impact and you're gonna make a
lot more money too
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below let me know what you think leave a
comment ask a question i'll make a video
response and subscribe if you want to
see more videos like this thank you so
much and i'll see you soon